Despite being an amazing but almost universal phenomenon
There are still many speculations about the role and value of orgasm here.
But which is better for the climax of what we know about women and men?
Female orgasm is longer than men, probably lasting 20 seconds or more
But most men last for three to five seconds.
But men will have more orgasms
In the Australian National Survey, heterosexual sex investigators found that male orgasm would last for 95% of the time.
When women only lasted for 69%
In any case, the climax may not have much to do with gender.
A greater relationship with it is the type of sex
For example, a study by a single American from the age of 21 to 26 found
The orgasm ratio of straight men and men is similar.
The ratio of female orgasm is clearly related to sexual orientation
Sexually, females have a 20% climax
Twenty-five percent of lesbians say
They will climax every time they experience
Almost half said they climaxed 75 percent of the time
This may be related to the length of sexual contact
When the lesbian couple reports an average length of thirty to forty-five minutes
In contrast, the average length of a straight girl is fifteen to thirty minutes.
Other explanations for genes
A study on the discovery of female twins
Genes predict the possibility of one-third of female orgasms
So how to explain the continuation of the climax
University students let men and women describe a climax
Then extract two specific words related to the genitals
This finds that there are only a few distinguishable differences between sexes
Regardless of your gender
The brain stimulates blood flow to the genitals and accelerates breathing
When pets show significant differences in exercise patterns in sexual arousal
Brain activity at the climax is the same as that of men and women
The area of ​​the lateral forehead brain area that controls self-assessment will be closed
All genders will be closed
This makes it difficult to lose control at the climax
Similarity is that people will feel tired after the climax
Due to a surge in sleep prolactin
Interestingly, four times prolactin is released after sexual intercourse.
Meet orgasm and masturbation
Means you won't feel tired when masturbating
We used to think that spontaneous climax is sleeping
At the same time, I think that spring dreams are only for men.
An academic survey indicates
37% of women have had a night climax
Thirty percent have had a night climax in the past few years
Multiple orgasms, one is considered a woman to have a phenomenon
Because of their tolerance during menstruation
Usually no male orgasm cumshot occurs at the same time
Studies have shown that men can climax without ejaculation
Ejaculation can be before or after climax
The sharing of this climactic experience makes it more rational from an evolutionary perspective
Just like when you see a person crying and feeling sad for him
Because you understand observation or as part of your partner's climax can enhance your desires and your own experience.
If we have completely different climax
Then the same connection will not have
End of the day
Sexual excitement between men and women
The main difference is that the climax experience is more like the difference to the individual level.
Physiological anatomy and psychology have played a big role
Understand your body and optimize your experience
You can always learn more about sexual pleasure during masturbation
Is masturbation in our video good for you?
The link describes the area below
Special thanks to the audible technical support for this episode
Give you a free 30-day course at audible.com/ASAP
This week we want to recommend this book "what if we're wrong"
Are all problems we feel we know in this world and what form they may appear in the future
You can wait until 30 days of free courses at audible.com/ASAP
Choose a huge choice
We love them and they are good when you go to their website to subscribe to them for more weekly science videos.